hey guys i'm here at the wired after
party after a long long week at CES and
to be honest has been kind of boring
microsoft was supposed to blow it out of
the water this year with their last
keynote and i almost fell asleep in the
middle of the conference trying to write
something up steve ballmer the CEO is
obviously supposed to be crazy as usual
and he didn't really talk about anything
there were no new products the one
person the one company that did surprise
me was nokia the company that i had
their their dumb phone in high school in
my backpack is now actually coming out
with a whole line of new smartphones to
take on Apple and Google and Android and
you know I don't know if they could do
it but it made me it made me excited to
see that at least someone is trying to
take on the big tech titans other than
that I know super cool innovations a lot
of stupid tablets that can go underwater
could probably get shot with one of them
and stop a bullet although I wouldn't
try that I was not willing to be a
tester and a whole lot of no sleep and
dirty bathrooms and and terrible food on
the show floor so I can't wait till next
year but as for me I'm going to go home
and get a heck of a lot of sleep
you